je vous écris aujourd'hui se trouvant
pas sur sub d'audika se fait longtemps
que je fasse deux vidéos sur ce jeu
c'est un jeu d'exploration au milieu
sous marin on va devoir survie on va
devoir racheter des trucs genre du
saumon fumé par exemple pour de nourrir
mediafire catastrophique de la coke
s'est produit durant la chute
gravitationnelle du vaisseau mineur aura
cause inconnue aucun signe de vie
détecté dans un rayon de cent mètres on
va aller à 110 m comme ça on trouvera un
pote aller ok donc on est dans notre
capsule de sauvetage on peut escalader à
l'échelle ho ho
c'est joli j'aime beaucoup alors est-ce
que moi pas devoir aller dans ce
vaisseau vinci a pas débat de la vie là
bas justement alors ça ah voilà alors ça
c'est le truc dans lequel va pas kraft
et à manger ou alors se faire des
équipements et tout ce à quoi bon bah
écoute et déjà on va devoir aller
chercher dans l'océan des kraft va pas
ce mytho et du poisson et aux divas en
360 ou casser ce bloc de calcaire et hop
on a du titane
oh merde ok on a une barre d'oxygène
c'est chaud ça pour nous ça regardez il
est wi-fi d'ajouter qu au hamas du sable
on va vraiment un homme et une blague
mais à quel moment le salsa vous être
utile bien là on va accuser le wat
charbonnel qu il soit pouvoir les
cuisines et où il faut un autre
ingrédient qu'on n'a pas cherché pas de
la crème fraîche par exemple paper
cuisinons c'est bon ça va le cuir oui
nous avons à pepper cuit qu'on va manger
vous êtes vous avez vu ça nous aggravons
remonter là là bas allez c'est super
varié du quartz là haut ça c'est quoi ça
champignons acide qui nous faudrait la
cdu couarde et du minerai quoi aux
débris métallique alors ça ça c'est un
tunnel mais c'est quoi le poisson c'est
un bon mec calme-toi et du comparation
corps poudre de poissons explosive
fragments de simone ckoi simone même pas
le ramasser c'est à dire ah [ __ ] de
frigo quoi c'est juste le frigo qui
contenait les bières dans le vaisseau
couteau survie il faut du caoutchouc en
silicone mais où tu joues du caoutchouc
ou silicone bon ok sinon en équipement
qui est ce qu'on peut avoir combinaison
de plongée en force et en tout cas il
faut du caoutchouc ainsi le code alors
c'est quoi on va retourner on va trouver
du caoutchouc en silicone tâche trouve
que du quartz mec c'est embêtant quand
même tête que c'est dans une eau donne
un petit peu plus loin c'est super joli
en tout cas j'adore par contre c'est
très oppressant d'être sous l'eau comme
ça j'aime pas du tout peut-être que
c'est là dans le caoutchouc pas du tout
ça suit caoutchouc ça oh oh tu as a
explosé à c'est complètement con côté en
danger de te suicider c'est débile on
n'a jamais vu ça [ __ ] la nuit approche
aux auteurs choisis qu'il a toujours
faire jour j'espère qu'ils la passent du
coup c'est joli regarder ça brille à mon
avis on doit pouvoir kraft et une lampe
on voit que dalle mais le truc et
sauteurs de l'eau au calme toi ou s'il
te plaît peu peur à tort têtu faut
décortiquer le poisson et la peau
élastique du poisson c'est ça le
caoutchouc
c'est faux alors qu'ils sont peu se fait
refuser clank mais ça en soi abbassi
regard des sources de sources de lumière
efficace ou l'autre est bien un
réservoir d'eau deux maux il faut du
verre on peut fabriquer des matériaux
aussi ah bah voilà le caoutchouc il se
fabrique bordel excellent avec du quartz
à butin des biens on peut faire une
usine de caoutchouc bordel à l'ephe les
voies du caoutchouc offert du verre
aussi ben voilà il a du coup va pouvoir
kraft et un plus grand réservoir
d'oxygène c'est bien ça voilà réservoir
d'eau de oh la la c'est vrai succès
déverrouiller non mais non mais là
abonnez vous et le couteau à la halle
avec quels débuts extraordinaire là du
coup on va pouvoir se faire les palmes
pour aller plus vite
bons achats c'est du plus gros poisson
et le pompe l'air de la surface un tuyau
walfer alors l'actuellement pour
construire d'autres trucs style et nous
faut un kit de câblage et donc du
minerai d'argent et le minerai d'argent
mon avis on va trouver plus en
profondeur
ok c'est reparti écouter on a notre
petit lumière pas ça s'arrête subitement
il fait chaud plus tard on a passé la
nuit à capter des trucs quel travailleur
c'est exceptionnel on a notre petit
couteau par compte et ça tu peux pas
m'échapper g kraft et des palmes est eu
plein de bonnes nouvelles du coup
maintenant avec le masque d'oxygène
qu'on attrape t on à 75 bon d'oxygène et
+35 doit pouvoir aller hyper profond
dans ta maman c'est faux toi j'ai envie
de te manger qui ressemble un peu à
gollum enfin le bouquet déjà mort ça se
mange pas [ __ ] c'est partir aura on
arrive j'ai envoyé aurora les fonds ils
sont beaucoup plus profond il veut qu'on
a vu qu'on a des cui yuma pouvoir y
aller mon gars j'espère qu'on va trouver
des minerais là ok on déploie un tuyau
hu
comment ça marche j'aurais dû me
renseigner avant au maire demande s'il
te plaît vie fais pas le con ça c'est
beau c'est bon ça passe
non mais tu crever en fait je pense
qu'il faut le mettre là ouais voilà
c'est ça ok en fait faut les relier tous
les tuyaux
hop on continue à mais on n'a pas assez
mois mais ses parades du coup on pourra
revenir là pour respirer comme ça à la
regarder ailleurs et regarder non ouais
c'est ça minerai de cuivre
oh la la c'est fantastique nous faut
trouver ce espèce de petit mode de
pierre là contre les murs
et là on a eu du titane n'a nulle à
chier dépôts de sel au c'est pas mal ça
on n'avait pas vu moi c'est bon on a
assez de minerai on va pouvoir retourner
à notre base par contre je suis
déshydraté comment faire pour s'hydrater
ça c'est une bonne question faut que je
fasse de l'eau mais comment on fait de
l'eau attendez un petit avec le sel
était un délire de de désinfection c'est
faut désinfecter il faut de la javel la
javel tu l'as fait comment mec avec du
sel et un échantillon de corail
ordinaire c ou le corail s'il vous plaît
si je tape là ah bah voilà échantillon
de corail faut juste tapé là dedans mon
gap ont pu voir un peu à +40 % c'est
cool ya un truc est cool qu'on peut se
faire
lampe torche ben voilà déploie l on va
faire une armoire pour stocker des du
matos ah ouais ok d'accord larmes
oualata qu'elle promet qu on va la
mettre là ok c'est super il est comme ça
du coup on peut stocker des trucs dedans
c'est génial une grave affaire utilisa
gravité artificiel pour attirer des
objets légers tombent et totalement
faire une gravissent faire la nuit
approche
ouais mais c'est pas grave parce qu'on a
et c'est parti en bouteille et la lente
ça éclaire beaucoup au oui assez
plaisant un régal et je veux juste
tester cet objet là
ça peut choquer le poisson le réacteur
de roja va exploser apparemment non
on veut et irradié mecs sont gelés
chassors theron la nuit pour faire
plaisir aux gens et pour s'amuser il ya
des radiations maintenant non non
combinaison antiradiations il me faut
deux plombs et du caoutchouc caoutchouc
c'est bon mais le plomb pour faire un
pont il faut 3 et cuivre et de l'argent
non mais please
écoutez on va quand même aller dans les
zones profondes qui sont là bas en
espérant qu'on se fasse pas irradiées la
gueule à tanger un poste en plus tard
radiations elles vont peut-être saft est
irradié des poissons qui vont devenir
des mutants qui vont vous exposer la
gueule oh oui oui c'est beau ça
m'aiderait d'argent radiation détectés
voilà voilà j'en étais sûr au quai le
jour se lève au moins c'est un petit peu
rassurant honoria des radiations [ __ ]
je suis en train de me faire exploser
tant qu'on n'aura pas de quoi faire la
combinaison en plomb sera totalement
baisers aux mecs ça c'est un poisson qui
a buté mon gas pas possible vous avez vu
ça ça son point faible sa boutade qui
nous a chié dessus en fait d'accord
comment je récupère de la vie moi la
malle à 7% de oui c'est juste impossible
j'ai crevé bonne nouvelle on peut faire
un plomb mauvaise nouvelle il nous faut
un deuxième plan pour faire la combi
entière aux cuves ou trois minerai de
cuivre et 1 d'argent j'en ai mal à ça me
gave l'accessoire de plomb bordel je
pète les plombs au à ça je le sens c'est
du fun radiation détectés non non vous
êtes mort et vous avez perdu du matériel
assez tout mais ça change rien de mourir
en fait mecque le seul jeu mourir ne
change rien si on va réussir à faire
cette combi de merde là un vrai un jour
tintin de merde voilà à puch un minerai
d'argent on est bons mots
[ __ ] tonnes jamais deux sans trois
[ __ ] de cuivre on est à 65 mètres du
titane mais c'est une blague
ouais ben y'en a pas un seul quoi c'est
extraordinaire
non allez vibrer d'argent et c'est du
cuivre avant terre-plein ecoutez jean
smart phone 7 sur sub de picasso
peinture manquons jouer puis je pense
qu'on a bien découvert les bases
ensemble c'était super bien voir comment
des jeux un milliard de fois je
comprends totalement pourquoi alors
sauté dans une prochaine vidéo merci
d'avoir regardé on refera peut-être une
vidéo sur sub nautica quand j'aurai
trouvé le minerai d'achat rang portez
vous bien très vite sur toulouse pis